Hey guys, and welcome to episode number
20 of my road to one bill series. Today
we're starting off at about 18 mil and
that is a bit of a jump from last time.
I know it's been a long time, but uh
last episode we finished at about 9 mil
plus 5 mil in the bank. Uh what we got
the money from was a runar run which we
had a full run to sell and uh could sold
one or two extra items and we ended up
with 18 mil.
What we're going to start off by doing
is upgrading our gear. So we're going to
buy a ring of fury
and uh sorry, a berserker ring and an
amulet of fury
um which I've never actually owned
before. Goals for this episode are going
to be to try to imbue the berserker
ring. We want to get a whip, level up
our attack, and um we're going to grind
up some barrels as well. So hope you
enjoy. All right, so we're at nightmare
zone. Um we're getting about 50k an hour
attack experience with um D dragon
scimitar. Uh so we're going to go for a
70 attack first and then we'll grind up
some defense levels I think cuz we need
70 defense before we can realistically
go for Zora.
One thing I forgot to mention is that
we're actually going to go ahead and
finish the digsite quest quickly
um because we want to get it for the uh
easy and medium Varrock achievement
diary so we can start banking those
battle staves every day. Uh just
something I've been meaning to get out
of the way for a long time and is a
source of kind of residual income. So I
thought I should really just get this
quest out of the way and I'll start off
on digsite. All right, so for this quest
that we're actually going to be using a
video quest guide. I've never done this
before, but we're using Slayer Music 1's
quest guide. Apparently it's pretty
good. Sounds pretty good so far and uh
we're just kind of running through uh
the digsite quest. Uh nothing special.
I've done this quest a couple times. Um
but it's a little lengthy. All right,
we're down this tunnel here. I think we
need arcania root uh cuz we are going to
be blowing up the tunnel.
Uh first we have to talk talk to Doug
Deeping.
Not sure I like that name.
All right, I think I just use this on
here
and light it and then it should blow up.
Ooh, we're going to see a sick
explosion.
Come on. Ooh,
just kind of a rumble. Eh, that's okay.
I was kind of hoping for more
explosions, but can't get everything, I
guess. All right, that should be the
Digsite quest completed. Uh 15,000
mining experience is actually pretty
nice. Some herbalore experience as well.
Uh but now we can go ahead and do the uh
achievement diaries for Varrock and uh
get the rewards uh that come with it.
All right, there we go. We have
completed the Varrock easy diaries. As
their name goes, they are pretty easy to
do. Um all you really need is the
Digsite quest and some really, really
low skill requirements. Um but there we
go. We have gotten the reward. Uh the
Varrock armor one gives you some random
thing to do with mining, and the XP lamp
is nice, but mainly we're doing this for
the battle staves you're going to get
every day. And I'll show you how to do
that in a minute, but from the easy
diaries, you're going to get about
30K profit every day, medium 60K, um
hard 120K, and elite 240K.
Uh you can see once you get the elites
done, that is pretty much almost
renewing a bond. Uh but all you do is
run up here, and in Zaff's staff shop,
uh he will have a barrel. Don't question
that too much, but there is staves in
there, and uh every day you can claim
them after a 24-hour period and get your
staves for 7K each. They really sell for
9K in the Grand Exchange, uh giving you
about uh the profits, like I said. So,
I'm glad to get this out of the way.
Something I should have done a long time
ago. So, now we can start accruing some
residual income every day and uh start
banking that for the one bill. All
right, so my goal for this episode was
to get 50 Barrows chests done. Um
originally, it was going to be 100, but
I think we're just going to do 50 for
now. Uh so, we're going to intertwine
this with training in the Nightmare
Zone, but we're going to grind out 50
chests, and hopefully we can get
actually some good loot.
All right, another Barrows chest coming
in. It's going to be uh
a fair amount of runes. All right, we're
five chests in, and this is going to get
us a sick reward of Bolts racks.
[__] yeah.
Chest number six is going to be more
Bolts racks. Number seven is again, more
Bolt racks. [__] Number eight is going
to be runes. At least I guess that's 50
K in runes. Chest number nine is more
runes.
Something worth mentioning is I don't
have the diaries done yet, which is
something I probably should consider
doing. But I need 70 agility and I
really don't want to [__] do that.
The next chest coming in is going to be
more runes unfortunately.
Nothing too special.
All right, here's the 13th chest. What
are we going to get from the legendary
Barrows brothers? Once we kill this rat,
it's going to be
a dragon med helm. [__] my life. All
right, we're taking a quick break from
Barrows and we're here in Nightmare
Zone. We're just AFK in NMZ. I think
we're about to hit an attack level,
which should bring us to 70 or 69
possibly attack. 69 attack. It's only
one more attack level so we can finally
wear the whip and ditch this dragon
scimitar that has been with us for a
very long time. All right, there we go
guys. There is 70 attack. Finally, we
can go and equip the dragon
abyssal whip. The abyssal whip. Not the
dragon abyssal whip. That would be cool,
but all we can really afford and wear is
the abyssal whip, which we will go ahead
and purchase shortly.
I'm getting pretty close to imbuing a
ring as well. We have 552 K reward
points and I think you need about 650 K
and then we can go ahead and imbue the
berserker ring as well, which will be
nice. I think we'll do the berserker
ring first and then our slayer helm
next. All right, we're back at Barrows
and now we have the abyssal whip to get
our kill count, which is pretty nice.
Having never actually used that before
in this account, it is pretty sweet. All
right, this is chest number 18. Can we
please get something?
Uh more runes in a shitty amount at that
honestly. Another chest coming in.
What's it going to be? 380 chaos runes.
Oh my god.
Who wants that many chaos runes? Chill.
All right, this is going to be chest
number 20 since we started this grind.
It's going to be a Dharok's platebody.
There we go, our first item of the 50
chest grind and a good one at that. That
is worth uh
I think over a mil.
Let's go ahead and price check that for
you guys.
Oh my god, can we get the right window
open here?
It's going to be worth 1.2 mil. That's
pretty nice. Happy with that. All right,
back with some more Barrows chests. Uh
these are actually on stream. So, next
one what's it going to be? Our epic loot
is 82 death runes.
It's kind of weak. All right, the next
chest uh number 22 is going to be the
Verac's brother.
What a surprise.
That was weird. All right, pretty lame
loot. Next chest is going to be more Bol
raps. Holy [__] people in the chat got
to stop calling Bol raps.
Next chest is more death runes.
That is chest number 24. So, we're about
halfway there. Uh 50 chests, we do about
10 an hour so far. Chest number 25 is
going to be
72 Bol raps, 82 death runes, and a pile
of crap. All right, on chest number 27
uh well
eh
All right, chest number 28. Come on,
another item, please.
Uh runes. I I think it's 1 in 15 chance.
We should be doing another item pretty
soon. All right, it's a new day and uh
we have upgraded a couple of our items
here. Um what we've also bought beyond
uh the toxic trident which we are using
right now, very good. We also bought a
cult necklace uh which you can see I
have on right now. Um Louis [__] But
anyway, now they're increasing my max
hit to 25, where before I believe it was
20. So, pretty substantial and uh really
wasn't that more expensive to get the
toxic trident. Oh my god, there it is,
guys. We've gotten the Torag's hammer
and the Dharok's greataxe in the same
chest. Wow. Well, there goes my luck.
But um
while neither of these are that valuable
per se,
um
I'm still pretty hyped to get those two.
Let's see how much they're worth. I
don't think they're worth more than a
couple hundred K each. Okay, that one's
worth 300 K and the Torag's hammers are
worth 100 K.
And Borax, but still, that's pretty
hype, guys. That is three Barrows items
so far in um about
36 chests. Can we get back-to-back
Barrows items?
No, we can't.
Oh, well. Can always dream, I guess. All
right, the next chest is going to be a
bunch of
poo, unfortunately. We really need that
50% extra rune reward.
All right, chest number 40 is going to
be
392 chaos runes. Holy crap, that is so
many chaos runes. All right, guys, we're
under 10 chests remaining and we can
finally finish our goal. Chest number
whatever. Torag's plate legs. Oh, man.
That was within another three chests.
Uh well, don't drop on the ground. Not
sure if these are worth very much,
either, but that's still pretty hype
getting those right away again. That's
three Barrows items so far on the stream
alone.
Um in total
in about
41 chests, we've gotten three items so
far, so that's pretty lucky.
Let's price check this. I'm not sure if
it's actually worth that much.
Uh 300 K. 300 K is 300 K. I will take
it. All right, eighth to last chest of
the episode is going to be
Borax.
Oh, well.
I really noticed this trident and occult
necklace has sped up my runs a lot. Uh
easily going through the Barrows
brothers. Again, not very good loot, but
the time is getting down and running
through the maze quickly. Uh so, I'm
getting much better at this, I would
say.
All right, it's a new day and another
stream. We only have five chests
remaining. Uh not a very good last five
chests,
um but pretty excited we're going to
actually finish these 50 episodes or 50
uh chests before the episode is
released. All right, chest number
46 is going to be a Guthans helm. Oh my
god, that is extremely lucky. That is
probably
the most expensive
Barrows piece, I think.
Wow, let's see how much this is worth
right now. It's over 2 mil, isn't it?
That is so lucky.
Uh people are going to hate me.
Uh well, let's get out of here first and
then price check that. Wow, that is
going to actually give us a decent
profit for all this now.
Um get the price checker open and it's
going to be worth
um
2.2
mil. That is extremely good. I'm so
happy with that. That was a really good
way to finish off these chests. It would
just be kind of greedy to ask for
another item at this point, wouldn't it?
Yeah, I mean that would just be kind of
unfortunate for me, not me.
For everyone else involved if I got
another item. People would start
unsubscribing from my channel. It just
wouldn't be fair.
Uh we actually just got a magic level in
here, uh which is really impressive
because you only get like 7 or 8k magic
experience an hour with the trident.
It's not very good. All right, second to
last chest is going to be um a bunch of
runes and I
might argue that is more. So, I'm not
really sure we get, but the 88% seems to
be making a difference possibly. Okay
guys, last chest, let's go. One more
Barrows item for the lols.
Can we get it?
No, we can't. But that's okay. We got
four Barrows items. Um wait.
Five?
Five Barrows items in total, sorry. Uh
so, we'll go ahead and do a price check
of everything. All right, there we go,
guys. That is the price check for the
Barrows runs. We got 6.1 mil in profit.
I would say we probably used about 1 mil
supplies, so we're banking about 5 mil
off of all this.
I'm pretty excited about that. I've not
really had a chance to do actually any
meaningful PvMing. Uh and this was a lot
of fun. Really enjoyed streaming it and
we got extremely lucky. Guthan's helm
coming in 2.2 mil, Dharok's platebody at
1.3 mil, and then a couple of other
peasant pieces. And uh quite a few in
runes. So, obviously I do need to get
the diaries done to get more runes which
I would like to get done eventually but
the requirements are 71 agility, 70
prayer. Those are going to be expensive
and time consuming. So they might not be
immediate plan but in the back burner
and will be done eventually. All right
guys, that is going to wrap it up for
today. I appreciate everyone who was
patient and waited for this episode to
come out. I thought I would do a little
bit more of a recap at the end cuz it
has been so long. So we did get 70
attack at Nightmare Zone.
On top of that we got our defense to 63.
Um we got a mage level which is nice. We
got a couple other levels in between
just some random stuff.
And but now for our bank uh we have 8.7
mil in cash. We now have the Trident of
the Swamp
and
um toxic blowpipe
occult necklace
uh seers' ring
and uh we do have that Barrows tab as
well our Barrows Barrows tab.
And anything else of value in here? Uh
well the runes from Barrows. So that's
worth 6 mil like you saw and items here
14 mil plus all this gear which has cost
me quite a bit. We also did buy an extra
Trident I believe.
Um
I maybe we sold that already.
Uh we still have a Trident of the seas.
So that is and that's charged I believe.
So that's a little bit more money there
and just some random stuff. I think our
bank's probably upwards of 25 mil or
something like that with everything said
and done and uh we'll try to maybe
liquidate some of that. We'll get rid of
our Barrows tab but I think we might do
more next episode. So appreciate
everyone who tuned in. Sorry it took so
long. We'll try to get them out a little
bit quicker in the future. See you guys
in the next episode.